Tired? We all know this feeling. Are you agitated? Stooped, and too lazy?
Looks like you did not sleep enough last night ... or the last few nights. But what time is enough
Who needs sleep? More importantly, can we meet that need?
While the same sleep function is still debated by scientists, but we know that our feedback is yet to come
Adequate sleep should be good. On the whole, we spend 24 years of our lives
In sleep, it is best to have this important topic. The researchers tested enough sleep time per night
Through long-term testing on groups of people sleep 4, 6, and 8 hours
After 14 days, the results showed that those who slept for 8 hours showed fewer mental deficits.
Those who slept 6 or 4 hours showed a significantly lower mental response. In fact, after
Only two weeks of a 6-hour group showed a similar reaction to people whose blood alcohol ratio was equivalent
Concentration of 0.10%, which is legally drunk. Those who sleep 4 hours suffer more ...
And sometimes sleep while taking mental and cognitive tests. In both groups ...
Day after day,